well
hello to you andrés gonzález an
informative insurance for today monday april 26
a man accused of killing one person
and injuring another on sunday
morning in the tourist area of ​​the strip
appeared in court today the
shooting happened  early Sunday morning
outside the hawai shopping center in
marketplace on las vegas boulevard
near harding street malik
flores, 25, is in custody and
faces murder and
attempted murder charges according to detectives the
reason for the shooting was an argument
between a group  of
men clark county is waiting for the
state to approve the plan they submitted
to reopen and loosen
distancing and capacity restrictions among the
most notable changes are increasing the
capacity limit from 50 to 80
percent and decreasing the
social distancing from 6 to 3
feet changes would take effect
by May 1st and would apply to
casinos restaurants gyms  and stores, he
also hopes to be able to resume
visits in prisons, if approved,
the plan would go to the
governor for a final approval.
Among the requirements to reopen the
economy is that the county's vaccination rate
be more than 60 percent
per  That same vaccination efforts have
increased and vaccination clinics are opening
throughout the valley. One of
these clinics is in the east of the valley and
will be open Tuesday and Wednesday at
the Hollywood Recreation Center from
4:00 pm to 8:00 pm
the other  clinic is scheduled for
thursday at the
senior center 16 sino exterior from
10 am to 2 pm and saturday at
the center va price from 9:30 to 3
pm
and when the economy opens  if it is also the
need to hire new
employees several companies are
holding job fairs this week
among them bob gale who will be
looking to hire people on wednesday
in e  he hotel golfos in particular are
looking to hire employees for their
food and beverage departments the
fair will be from 11 in the morning to 3 in the
afternoon
now let's look at the weather forecast
we will have cloudy skies for the
start of the week with the possibility of
rain for today and tomorrow and
for Friday the temperatures will rise
to 80 and 90 degrees for the
weekend this the information for the
moment wishes you a happy day
I am andrés gonzález and this was about
informative the end is now in  Spanish